[Musica]
a quanti di voi hanno detto che non ce
l'avreste mai fatta che sarebbe stato
impossibile
beh a me lo hanno ripetuto in tanti sono
cresciuta con la parola impossibile
quando avevo dieci anni la maestra pina
disse mio padre che ero stupida perché
non riuscivo a capire le divisioni
esattamente sette anni dopo fu
selezionata per le olimpiadi della
matematica in rappresentanza del museo
arrivai fino alle semifinali nazionali
ma in ogni caso la matematica non
sarebbe mai stata la mia più grande
passione ma mi sarebbe comunque tornata
utile qualche anno dopo le lingue e lo
sport però si quelle mi piacevano da
morire quando un giorno scoprì che mio
fratello più piccolo faceva lezioni
private di inglese costrinse i genitori
a portare anche me ma lo sapevate che
per viaggiare non vi serve il passaporto
infatti vi basta imparare le lingue
così un giorno decise di iniziare a fare
il bagaglio con mia madre prima
destinazione goethe institut corso di
tedesco
da lì poi passò il passo fu breve
spagnolo portoghese francese fino al
polo nord con il norvegese
ah dimenticavo latino e greco con la
colla maturità al liceo classico di
antonello venditti e lo sport
beh sono sempre stata una bambina molto
sportiva non mi fermavo un attimo ho
praticato tantissimi sport della
pallavolo atletica al triathlon alla
danza al tennis
insomma non mi annoiavo mio fratello
tentò anche di insegnarmi a giocare a
calcio ma capì che non faceva per me
quando un giorno mi misero in porta
almeno lì avrei smesso di prendere a
calci sugli stinchi tutti i suoi amici
impossibile è scandaloso ma perché la
spingete non è un mondo per lei
lasciate stare le farete sulla mente del
male
queste le parole che i miei genitori
dovettero ascoltare per qualche tempo
forse anche troppo ebbene sì asso lividi
e 16 anni
decisi di fare l'arbitro di rugby
probabilmente vi starete chiedendo ma
come ci è finita questo a soli 16 anni
in mezzo a trenta energumeni
e bene cercherò di spiegarvelo in poche
parole innanzitutto pensate ad una
ragazza timidissima che ha paura anche
della propria ombra perfettina ed in
decisa a tal punto che se le chiedete se
vuole un bicchiere d'acqua naturale
odono frizzante non sa nemmeno cosa
rispondervi
aggiungete poi il fatto che ha due
fratelli che giocano a rugby ed una
sorella che più tardi avrebbe seguito le
sue orme
mio padre ancora ricorda il giorno in
cui mi presentai per la prima volta al
palazzo del coni per il corso arbitri
solo uomini età media 25 30 anni ed io
bambina sedicenne tutti pensavano che
fosse mio padre a dover fare il corso no
no no ero io avevo trovato pane per i
miei denti
era la mia sfida ma non sapeva cosa
stesse andranno incontro primo ostacolo
confrontarmi con me stessa e gli altri
in campo
mia sorella ancora ricorda i pomeriggi
passati davanti allo specchio ad
esercitarmi con la gestualità e il
fischio ebbene sì perché un buon arbitro
bisogna saperlo riconoscere dalla
gestualità e dal fischio proprio così
bene secondo ostacolo acquisire rispetto
in campo
ebbene sì senza perdere la mia
femminilità femminilità perché sono una
donna in un mondo di uomini e non per
questo mi devo snaturare easter donna è
un valore aggiunto non bisogna
vergognarsene così imparai fin da subito
che il mio motto era sia autorevole ma
mai autoritaria rispetta e sarai
rispettato nel rugby per avanzare
bisogna passare la palla indietro ma
avete mai provato a tirare una palla da
rugby bene sapete dove lo tirate non
sapete mai dove va a finire
un po come la mia vita la vostra vita la
nostra vita
l'arbitro sbaglia
l'arbitro non è perfetto l'arbitro è
umano eppure nessuno ci crede ai solo
vent'anni non avrei scommesso nemmeno un
centesimo su di te ma oggi devo dire di
essermi sbagliato di grosso
2013 universiadi di kazan arbitro della
finale di bronzo
da quel giorno il bagaglio che avevo
iniziato da tempo a preparare con mia
madre aveva iniziato a prendere il volo
fin da bambino ho amato sempre volare
nel mondo dei sogni
sì perché lì anche l'impossibile può
divenire realtà e così che ha solo 23
anni
mi ritrovai come unica rappresentante
italiana alle olimpiadi di rio
all'esordio del rugby esattamente sette
anni dal mio esordio
il mio sogno si era realizzato il
vincitore è colui che non ha mai smesso
di sognare
ebbene con gli anni ho imparato che
bisogna in continuare a sognare anche ad
occhi aperti e bisogna continuare a
sognare e saper fare sacrifici e
soprattutto avere un obiettivo ben
preciso la vita non è tutta rose e fiori
la vita ti coglie alla sprovvista ti fa
cadere e bisogna imparare rialzarsi la
vita ti coglie non ti prepara non sai
mai quello che ti aspetti una botta il
buio il silenzio di qualche istante non
ricordo
non ricordo un giocatore due giocatori
il fischietto in terra guardo il
cronometro mancano 15 secondi alla fine
della partita ma io non ricordo
lui mi guarda mi fa un sorriso di sfida
io capisco ricordo ora mi sale un
brivido di freddo
allora prendo il fischietto lo porto in
bocca e decide di portare a termine
negli ultimi 15 minuti della partita
signorina benvenuti non so se lei è
credente ma qualcuno le ha messo una
mano in testa lei oggi sarebbe dovuta
arrivare su una sedia a rotelle o non
sarebbe mai arrivata
entrò nel tubo della risonanza passano
secondi minuti che per me sembrano ore i
giorni passano le designazioni sono
perse non so se riesco a ritornare in
campo ma il mio primo pensiero è
rientrare lì a rientrare in campo quando
non lo so ma voglio che sia il prima
possibile
la chiamano resilienza quella capacità
di tracciare sentieri dove vi sono
solamente buche ed ostacoli
quell'abilità di chi camuffa una
bruttissima caduta con un magnifico volo
e di chi non si focalizza tanto su
quante volte accaduto ma piuttosto su
quante volte si è rialzato io la chiamo
voglia di vivere di sognare di fallire
di cadere e rialzarsi ancora più forti e
motivati di prima
io la chiamo voglia di sognare e di
continuare non mollare mai perché sono
proprio le vette raggiunte con il sudore
e il sacrificio quelle che offrono i
panorami migliori
ebbene il rugby è stata la mia scuola di
vita ed il perché fosse così scandaloso
che io a 16 anni entrassi in un mondo
prevalentemente maschile è diventata una
motivazione abbastanza forte da poter
superare qualsiasi come è bene quante
volte vi hanno detto continua per quella
strada vai avanti a testa alta puoi
farcela fa per te beh voglio dirvelo io
oggi nella speranza che gli tra di voi
ci siano tante piccole e meno piccoli me
che hanno voglia di inseguire i propri
sogni che hanno voglia di superare i
pregiudizi e di sfondare qualche porta e
portoni in più se ce l'ho fatta io
potete farcela anche voi grazie
[Applauso]